why is Rogan so all over the rock yeah I
will tell you why I will tell you why
you know back in the 90s these
bodybuilders which was a very uh unique
thing that these guys did and it was
kind of funny It's the funniest video
which one old video of bodybuilders with
their faces let me see if I can find
this clip uh old um
uh um
face yeah that's the one where they're
saying you know I use steroids yeah I do
this but they have their faces blurry as
if nobody can tell who it is because
there's only a few people that are that
massive and they're telling the truth
about steroids but no bodybuilder wanted
to say that they're on steroids it was
like that one secret thing that you
wouldn't tell anybody yeah everybody
knew they were doing it yeah nobody
wanted to reveal that they're doing it
right kind of like smoking weed back in
the days was like Hey this guy's smoking
weed you know he's this where today it's
kind of like yeah okay you know people
look in a different way not go we're not
endorsing it we're just saying it's you
want to smoke cigarettes go you want to
smoke weed go today you know when you're
like I'm naturally this big right I'm
naturally this big this is all natural
let me relax bro like you know when it's
like these are my natural breasts yeah
we had we had one lady that we work with
where
I I was there when she got the the
procedure done 15 years later in a
meeting saying mine are natural I'm like
this so some people are like listen man
what what do you well like what do you
get from saying that like yeah so that
is the part where some people just don't
like when if you're on it just say
you're on it no one cares about steroids
the way they did 30 years ago but some
people just want to say I'm naturally
like this because I have great genetics
yeah because that's on the different
story though back because some because
trt I'm getting Facebook ads of hey if
you're low on testosterone they'll give
you an you know you can get injections
every week trt but that is that it's a
form of steroids that doesn't ask is it
is that still seriously Joe Rogan admits
that he's on it he's on trt of course
he's talked about it openly but again
why why do 11 million people tune into
Joe Rogan
interesting good good interviews and
he's honestly Straight
From the Heart I'm just Joe Rogan this
is who I am I do steroids I smoke with
I'm not going to drink this month I can
do you know such and such we're gonna do
this and we're going to do that and he
opinions I don't know I used to I like
Bernie Sanders I don't know about this
now I like this he's just like he's
evolving in front of your face
everybody's growing up with him like you
know if you were to say who Joe is Joe
is the modern day Johnny Carson for
podcasts people freaking loved Johnny
Carson period so all he's saying is if
you're using it do just talk about your
use them who gives a [ __ ] nobody cares
but don't act like you're naturally that
big because you're not yeah and Rogan's
also a renaissance man whether it's
comedy whether it's UFC whether it's
intellectual whether it's asking good
questions whether it's like I saw just
he does his ice bath thing every morning
it hurts it's just he's so well-rounded
and people respect him uh and I don't
understand the beef with with with the
rock though yeah
there is there is conflict out there
because the Rock's been in men's health
talking about Cod that how much Cod he
eats every day he puts it the fish yeah
okay puts in these containers and it's
like two and a half pounds of cod every
day with no oil no butter and so there
have been times where he seems like he's
gone out there on a limb Pat and to say
oh this is my this is my routine I lift
it this time and so I was just curious
what that spark was that got Rogan to
say hey dude I think he doesn't like
[ __ ] artists and by the way there's
a part of it that here's what another
thing people don't like about what rocks
done a couple times which is is uh I I
supported stuff that he does I buy his
shoes I have his shirt I've watched
Black Adam I thought it was a okay movie
I thought it was better than other DC
movies I don't say it's the greatest DC
movie of all time
but uh you know it's almost a feeling I
got with uh talking to our guest
yesterday is so concerned about what
everybody in their world will say like
he comes out supporting Joe Rogan and
then a video comes out of Joe Rogan of
what he said 15 years ago very
disappointed to see this I can't support
that and then what what it's like okay
you know I understand you know you're
doing what you're doing and then same
thing he did with Logan Paul where hey
he's doing all this stuff with Logan and
then telling Logan take all the picture
of us down because they had the same
agent that's probably the part that
doesn't sit well uh with Joe yeah I
don't know I haven't spoken to Joe about
this but that's probably what doesn't
said well I may be fully wrong I'll tell
you what's unique about Joe because
whether you're talking about our guests
yesterday whether you're talking about
the rock whether you're talking about
politicians A-list actors once you've
made it
you don't want to like you don't want to
say anything or do anything to put you
back to normalcy like you just want to
play it safe it's almost like that
conversation we brought up yesterday
when you spoke to the billionaire yeah
where he basically said there's two
types of people in the world there's the
people have already made their billions
and they just want to keep it versus the
person that's still on the come up and
trying to grind and trying to make that
money but if you're if you're in this
camp and you've you're already worth
hundreds of millions of dollars of
billions of dollars or you're a public
figure the last thing you want to do is
get you know chopped down and go back to
down to the bottom of the totem pole
everything we've seen with me too and
cancel culture and you know believer all
women everything you got to play it
close to the vest these days and I think
that's why people respect Rogan is
because despite being an a-lister
despite making all the money he's still
like I'm still me baby I'm still me and
that's why he has so much respect but
most people are going to kind of play it
close to the vest so they don't have to
deal with their look remember business
together I expect you to defend me I
expect you to support me I expect you to
to you know uh have my back there's a
relationship kind of like all the people
you know Joe they have that relationship
but you know if you're off I'm gonna say
hey man you're off you know I I don't
agree and then we can hash it out and
have a conversation on certain things
that we do some of it is private some of
it is public some of it is no one's
business on what you do you you know
what I'm saying and then in the space
like when you're somebody that's the
best in your space chose the goat in his
space and rock is a high speed actor of
all time he's that he's the goat of his
space in you know 124 million dollars he
made in a year I think those records are
going to be broken two years ago Forbes
said he made one 24 in a year in 2019.
that's a big number right there to make
as an actor there's a mutual respect of
like Federer hanging out with Tiger
Woods Roger Federer doesn't say you know
what tiger after what came out with
those 16 girls you and I can no longer
talk to each other yeah can you imagine
if Roger said that's like I don't know I
I don't listen they have a relationship
who Roger and tigers Michael Jordan
all I'm saying is goats with goats
there's a certain level of mutual
respect you ought to have for that but
Hollywood makes some of these guys
actually scared and they back off a
little bit because they're worried about
what the public is it's the life you
live like what rock what the uh uh Tate
calls out
do what he uses the Matrix is they're
they're they're bowing Down to What a
publicist is telling them to say
okay and and you ought to have a
conversation with that person but
there's different kind of publicist like
we had a galver at our house two nights
ago I said uh he says look let me tell
my specialty is here's my specialties
uh challenges companies go through where
it's like social media or online crisis
you're going through and everybody's
targeting your definition of character
let me tell you what the traditional PR
form will tell you to do traditional P
offering will tell you here's the format
of the letter to write of the tweet and
the video to make on how to apologize he
says that's not us
here's what we do we say yeah I effed up
here I man for this but let me also go
back and say this
and I boom so the format of Hollywood is
this format I'm sorry I apologize
I'll get better which is fine I get
better is fine but it's constant like
fear of losing this
Spotlight the favors from Hollywood it's
too much and look some people can do it
there's a lot of people that cannot do
it so with all the craziness taking
place I believe future looks bright if
you believe future looks bright get your
latest Future looks bright hat of
valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red or black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people wore it in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody saying future looks spread toward
your future looks bright hat click over
here and to watch the entire podcast
click here take care everybody
foreign